This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedenthu. There are certain issues where we just don't see eye to eye with people on the other side of the political aisle. Often it feels like we don't just disagree over policy, we can't even agree on the facts. I think people are mostly just setting their ways. I would say I'm right objectively, The facts prove that there is global warming. I don't know how you can dispute it. But everybody thinks they're right. I think they're wrong.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在某些政治议题上，我们与政治光谱另一端的人根本无法达成共识。通常感觉我们不仅是在政策上意见不合，甚至连基本事实都无法达成一致。我认为人们大多只是固执己见。我会说我是客观正确的，事实证明全球变暖是存在的。我不知道你怎么能对此产生异议。但每个人都认为自己是对的。我认为他们错了。
I think they're making a huge mistake because security has to be a very big issue. My guest today has spent years studying the way we process information and why we often reach biased conclusions. She says it's surprisingly difficult for us to change one another's minds no matter how much data we present. But just a little bit of emotion, that can go a long way. Tali Sharot is a cognitive neuroscientist at University College London. In her upcoming book, The Influential Mind, she explores how our minds work, why we ignore the facts, and how you can get people to actually listen to the truth.
我认为他们犯了个大错误，因为安全必须是一个非常重大的问题。我今天的嘉宾花了很多年时间研究我们处理信息的方式以及为什么我们经常得出有偏见的结论。她说，无论我们提供多少数据，要想改变彼此的想法都难得惊人。但只要有一点点情感，就能发挥很大作用。塔利·沙罗特是伦敦大学学院的认知神经科学家。在她即将出版的新书《影响力的大脑》中，她探讨了我们的大脑是如何工作的、我们为什么会忽视事实，以及如何才能让人们真正听取真相。
Tally, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you, great to be here. Some months ago, you were listening to a Republican presidential debate, and candidate Donald Trump was asked a question about the safety of childhood vaccines. Here's what he said. You take this little beautiful baby and you pump. I mean, it looks just like it's meant for a horse, not for a child.
塔利，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢，很高兴来到这里。几个月前，你在收听一场共和党总统辩论，候选人唐纳德·特朗普被问及一个关于儿童疫苗安全性的问题。他是这么说的。你把这个美丽的小宝宝抱来注射。我的意思是，这看起来就像是给马准备的，而不是给孩子准备的。
And we've had so many instances, people that work for me just the other day. Two years old, two and a half years old, the child, the beautiful child went to have the vaccine and came back and a week later got a tremendous fever, got very, very sick, now is autistic. Tali, you're a mom. You have two small children. At the time, Trump said this, one of your kids was two years old, the other was seven weeks old. Describe your emotional reaction to what he said. weeks old, describe your emotional reaction to what he said. Yes, so when I was listening to Trump at that debate, I was already quite concerned because I was a mother of a small child, so you're always concerned about the health and safety of your kids, especially when they're only a few weeks old.
我们遇到过这么多实例，就在前几天，我手下员工的孩子。两岁，两岁半的孩子，那个美丽的孩子去打了疫苗，回来后一个星期烧得厉害，病得非常重，现在得了自闭症。塔利，你是一位母亲。你有两个小孩子。特朗普说这话时，你的一个孩子两岁，另一个只有七周大。请描述一下你听到他这话时的情感反应。是的，当我听到特朗普在辩论中这么说时，我已经相当担忧了，因为我是一个小孩子的母亲，所以你总是担心孩子的健康和安全，尤其是当他们只有几周大时。
And so it really tapped into this fear that I had and the anxiety that I already had. And when he talked about this huge syringe, a horse-sized syringe that was going to go into the baby in my mind, I could imagine this syringe inserted into my small little child and all the bad things that could happen. And this was a very irrational reaction on my end because I know that there's not an actual link between autism and vaccines, but it's not enough to have the data. Ben Carson, Dr. Ben Carson, was on the other end. Well, let me put it this way. There has been numerous studies and they have not demonstrated that there's any correlation between vaccinations and autism. But that wasn't enough because the data is not enough.
所以这确实触动了我的这种恐惧和早已存在的焦虑。当他谈到这个巨大的注射器、一个马匹大小的注射器将要扎进婴儿体内时，在我的脑海里，我能想象这个注射器插入我幼小孩子体内的情景，以及所有可能发生的坏事。我这是一种非常不理性的反应，因为我知道自闭症和疫苗之间并没有实际的联系，但仅有数据是不够的。本·卡森，本·卡森博士，持相反观点。好吧，让我这么说吧。已经有很多研究表明，疫苗接种与自闭症之间没有任何关联。但这还不够，因为数据是不够的。
And even if the data is based on very good science, it has to be communicated in a way that will really tap into people's needs, their desires. If people are afraid, we should address that. I'm curious when you sort of contrasted, you know, the weight of the evidence on the one hand and this very powerful image of the horse syringe and your seven-week old baby on the other hand, how did you talk yourself into trusting the data over that emotional image?
而且，即使数据基于非常好的科学，它的传达方式也必须能够真正契合人们的需求和欲望。如果人们感到害怕，我们就应该解决这个问题。我很好奇，当你把一方面的大量证据与另一方面关于马用注射器和七周大婴儿的强烈意象进行对比时，你是如何说服自己相信数据而不是那种情感意象的？
What really helped is that I understood what was happening to me. You know, the first instinct was like a stress and anxiety, but because this is what I study, I knew what my reaction was. I knew where it was coming from. I knew how it was going to affect me, and I think that awareness helped me to put it aside and say, okay, I know that I am anxious for the wrong reasons, and this is the action that I should take. It's a little bit when you're on a plane, and there's turbulence, and you get scared. But telling yourself, I know that turbulence is not actually anything that's dangerous. I know the statistics on safety and planes and so on, it helps. It helps people reduce their anxiety.
真正有帮助的是我理解了自己身上发生了什么。你知道，第一直觉是压力和焦虑，但因为这是我研究的领域，所以我知道我的反应是什么。我知道它来自哪里。我知道它将如何影响我，我认为这种觉察帮助我把它放在一边，并对自己说，好吧，我知道我的焦虑是由于错误的原因，这是我应该采取的行动。这有点像你在飞机上遇到气流感到害怕的时候。但你告诉自己，我知道气流其实并没有什么危险。我知道飞机安全等方面的统计数据，这很有帮助。它有助于人们减轻焦虑。
The facts don't always relieve our anxieties, though. Sometimes, they only harden our views. Some time ago, Tally did a study where she presented information to people who believe that climate changes real and to people who are skeptics. She found, for both groups, people strengthened their pre-existing beliefs when new information confirmed what they thought, but both groups ignored information when it challenged their views. I asked Ali about this. Our psychological biases are the same across individuals on average.
不过，事实并不总能缓解我们的焦虑。有时候，它们只会让我们固执己见。不久前，塔利做了一项研究，她向相信气候变化真实存在的人和怀疑论者提供信息。她发现，对这两组人来说，当新信息证实他们的想法时，他们会强化原有的信念，但当信息挑战他们的观点时，两组人都选择忽视。我问了塔利关于这方面的问题。平均而言，我们在个体之间的心理偏差是相同的。
We all have what's known in a confirmation bias. A confirmation bias is our tendency to take in any kind of data that confirms our prior convictions and to disregard data that does not conform to what we already believe. And when we see data that doesn't conform to what we believe, what we do is we try to distance ourselves from it. We say, well, that data is not credible, right? It's not good evidence for what
我们都有所谓的确认偏误。确认偏误是我们倾向于接受任何能证实我们原有信念的数据，而忽视不符合我们既有信念的数据。当我们看到不符合我们信念的数据时，我们会试图与之保持距离。我们会说，好吧，这些数据不可信，对吧？它不能很好地证明它所说的话。所以我们试图重新构建它来抹黑它。我想就一个问题反驳你一下，那就是有时在我看来，拒绝传入的数据其实可能是理性的。你知道，如果我一生都看到重力在起作用，它让物体向地面下落。而你把我带到一个物体似乎在悬浮的房间里。在我看来，恰当的反应不应该是“好吧，我关于重力的一切认知都是错的”，而是“让我试着去理解这个反常现象”。
it's saying. So we're trying to reframe it to discredit it. I want to sort of push back at you just on one point, which is sometimes it seems to me that it actually might be rational to reject data that comes in. You know, if I've seen gravity work all my life, it makes objects fall toward the ground. And you take me into a room where an object seems to be levitating. It seems to me the appropriate reaction is not okay, everything I knew about gravity was wrong, but let me try and understand this anomaly.
让我试着去理解为什么这个物体没有按它应该做的那样去做。在我看来——而且我在这里显然暴露了我自己的信念——鉴于气候变化真实存在的压倒性证据，向我展示一个冬天的气温比正常情况冷的数据，不应该改变我对整体情况的看法。难道不是吗？你完全说得对。所以人们倾向于更新自己信念的方式是，根据他们原有的信念来使用新信息，因为平均而言，这是理性的做法。正如你所说，当我们遇到某些与我们深信不疑的信念相矛盾的信息时，平均而言，这些信息是错误的。所以我会在书中举个例子：如果有人走进来，说我刚刚看到粉红色的象在天空飞翔，而我有一个非常坚定的信念，即粉红色的象不会在天空飞翔。
Let me try and understand why this object is not doing what it's supposed to do. It seems to me, and I'm clearly betraying my own beliefs here, given the overwhelming weight of evidence that climate change is real, showing me data that one winter is colder than normal shouldn't make me change my overall view. Should it? You're absolutely right. So the way that people tend to update their beliefs is that they use the new information in light of what they already believe because that on average is the rational way to go. Exactly as you said, when we encounter some kind of information that really contradicts what we believe very, very strongly on average that information is wrong. So I give an example in my book where if someone comes in and says, I just saw pink elephants flying in the sky, and I have a very strong
我就会认为他们要么产生幻觉，要么在说谎，我有充分的理由相信这一点。所以根据你的信念来评估数据其实是正确的方法。决定我们是否会改变信念有四个因素：我们原有的信念、对那个原有信念的信心、新的数据片段，以及我们对那个数据片段的信心。数据片段距离你原有的信念越远，它改变你信念的可能性就越小；平均而言，在日常生活中，这并不是一种糟糕的方法。然而，这也意味着要改变错误信念真的很难。因此，如果一个人坚定地抱持某种信念，但那是一个错误信念，用数据很难改变它。当我们回来时，我们将讨论一些重塑他人或我们自己信念的方法，并试图回答这个问题：如果向人们灌输好的信息并不能将错误信息逐出流通领域，你该如何让人们接受真相？
belief obviously that no pink elephants fly in the sky. I would then think that they're either delusional or they're lying, and there's good reason for me to believe that. So it's actually the correct approach to assess data in light of what you believe. There's four factors that determine whether we're going to change our beliefs. Our old belief are confidence in that old belief, the new piece of data, and our confidence in that piece of data. And the further away the piece of data is from what you already believe, the less likely
请继续收听。通常人们会觉得恐惧被用来激励我们采取行动。当今绝大多数美国人并没有感到安全。周日，美国人在一种已经变得令人麻木的熟悉噩梦中醒来。这可能是史上最大的特洛伊木马。政客们用恐惧来让我们投票。电视节目用恐惧来让我们继续观看。公共卫生官员用恐惧来让我们戒烟。我问塔利，恐惧是否可能是说服人们改变想法甚至行为的有效方法。
it is to change your belief, and on average, as you go about the world, that is not a bad approach. However, it also means that it's really hard to change false beliefs. So if someone holds a belief very strongly, but it is a false belief, it's very hard to change it with data. When we come back, we're going to talk about some of the ways we can reshape the beliefs of other people or our beliefs and try and answer the question, if throwing good information at people doesn't drive misinformation out of circulation, how do you get people to buy the truth?
恐惧在两种情况下起作用。它在人们已经准备好、承受压力时起作用，而且在你想让某人不做某事（即不采取行动）时也起作用。例如，如果你试图让人们不给孩子接种疫苗，恐惧可能会起作用。如果有，你知道的，一个看起来很坏的苹果，我就不吃它。事实上，恐惧并不是激发行动的好催化剂，
Stay with us. In often fields as though fear is used to motivate us to act. The vast majority of Americans today do not feel safe. On Sunday, Americans woke up to a nightmare that's become mind-numbingly familiar. This could be the great Trojan horse of all time. Politicians use fear to get us to vote. TV programs use fear to get us to keep watching. Public health officials use fear to get us to quit smoking. I asked Tally whether fear might be an effective way
而希望通常是激发行动的更好催化剂。你在书中谈到一个研究，一家医院设法让其员工践行手部卫生，让员工定期洗手。但事实证明，最有效的做法并不是让员工对传播感染的风险感到恐惧。
to persuade people to change their minds and maybe even their behavior. Fear works in two situations. It works when people are ready, stressed out, and it also works when what you're trying to do is get someone not to do something, an inaction. For example, if you try to get someone not to vaccinate their kids, fear may work. If there's, you know, an apple that looks bad, I don't eat it. Fear is actually not such a good motivator
是别的东西。因此，在东海岸的一家医院，安装了一个摄像头，以观察医务人员在进入和离开病房前后真正对手部进行消毒的频率。医务人员知道摄像头已经安装好了，然而在进入和离开病房前后，只有十分之一的医务人员对手部进行消毒。但随后引入了一项干预措施，一个电子显示板被放置在每扇门上方，它向医务人员提供实时的积极反馈。它向他们展示了当前轮班中洗手的医务人员百分比以及每周的比率。所以，任何时候只要有医务人员洗手，数字就会立即上升，并且会出现积极反馈，比如“干得好”。这显著影响了人们洗手的可能性。它从10%上升到了90%，并且保持在这个水平。
for inducing action, while hope is a better motivator on average for motivating action. You talk about one study in your book where a hospital managed to get its workers to practice hand hygiene, to get its workers to practice hand hygiene to get staff members to wash their hands regularly. But it turned out the most effective thing was in frightening the staff about the risks of transmitting infections.
他们没有采用常规的方法，没有说“你知道的，你必须洗手，否则你会传播疾病”，基本上没有警告他们未来可能发生的所有坏事（这实际上会导致不作为），而是给了他们积极反馈。塔利探索过的一个重要概念被称为“平等启发法”。这是一种心理捷径，其实非常简单。我们倾向于赋予每个人的意见相等的权重。但有时，当房间里有一位专家时，
It was something else. So in a hospital on the east coast, a camera was installed to see how often medical staff actually sanitize their hand before and after entering a patient's room. And the medical staff knew that the camera was installed, and yet only one in ten medical staff sanitized their hands before and after entering a patient's room. But then an intervention was introduced, an electronic board that was put above each door, and it gave the medical staff in real-time positive feedback. It showed them the percentage of medical staff that washed their hands in the current shift and the weekly rate as well. So, any time a medical staff will wash their hands, the numbers will immediately go up and there will be a positive feedback saying, you know, good job. And that affected the likelihood of people washing their hands significantly. It went up from 10% to 90% and it stayed there.
这种心理捷径会把我们引入歧途。不同的人有不同的专业知识，最好把更多的权重放在那些更有知识或在我们做出决策的领域拥有更多专业知识的人身上。并且有一项研究表明，这种平等启发法是世界各地的人都会做的事情。所以这并不是人们只在民主政府中才会做的事情，
Instead of using the normal approach, instead of saying, you know, you have to wash their hands because otherwise you'll spread the disease, basically instead of warning them of all the bad things that can happen in the future, which actually results in inaction, they gave them positive feedback. One important idea that Tally has explored is something known as the Equality Heuristic. It's a mental shortcut, and it's really quite simple. We tend to assign equal weight to everyone's opinion. But sometimes, when there's an expert in the room,
但在其他国家，如中国和伊朗，也进行过研究，在那里人们同样遵循平等启发法。如果他们需要做出决定，他们会收集相当一部分个人的意见，然后把它们汇总起来，这就是他们做出决定的方式。而不是真正利用房间里那个更有知识、更有专业专长的人。但你怎么知道谁是专家呢？当你的问题关于癌症时，你可以求助于肿瘤学家。
this mental shortcut can lead us astray. Different people have different expertise, and it's better to put more weight on people who are more knowledgeable or have more expertise in the domain that we're making the decision in. And there's been a study showing that this equality heuristic is something that people do around the world. So it's been a study showing that this equality heuristic is something that people do around the world. So it's not something that people do
但对于其他问题，许多人可能自称见多识广。事实证明，有一种巧妙的技术可以将专家与冒名顶替者区分开来。这被称为“惊人受欢迎的投票”。让我用一个例子向你展示它是如何运作的。我有两个问题要问你。第一个是，巴西的首都是哪里？好了，这是第二个问题。你认为大多数人会说巴西的首都是哪里？好了，这是第二个问题。你认为大多数人会说巴西的首都是哪里？也许你认为首都是里约热内卢，但也许你知道正确答案是巴西利亚。通过查看这两个快速民意调查的结果，我在没有任何先前信息的情况下可以告诉你，巴西的首都是巴西利亚。
only in democratic governments, but studies have been conducted in other countries such as China and Iran, and there too people go according to the equality heuristic. If they need to make a decision, they will get the opinions of quite a few individuals and then tell you them up and that's how they make the decision. Instead of actually using the person in the room who is more knowledgeable and has more expertise. But how can you know who the expert is? When your question is about cancer, you can turn to a non-collegeist.
我怎么会知道呢？因为如果我认为里约热内卢是巴西的首大部分，我也会认为大多数人这么认为。然而，如果我认为巴西利亚是巴西的首都，我仍然会认为里约是大多数人会给出的答案。所以最终的结果是，巴西利亚将是一个比人们预期更受欢迎的答案。我必须说，我花了一会儿才理解这个概念是如何运作的。这很复杂，但确实非常巧妙。这里有另一个例子。我们来看一道数学题。在一个湖里，有一片睡莲。每一天，这片睡莲的面积都会翻倍。如果这片睡莲覆盖整个湖泊需要48天，那么它覆盖半个湖泊需要多长时间？
But for other questions, many people might claim to be knowledgeable. It turns out there's a clever technique to separate the experts from the pretenders. It's called the surprisingly popular vote. Let me show you how it works with an example. I have two questions for you. The first is, what's the capital of Brazil? Okay, here's the second question. What do you think most people will say is the capital of Brazil? Okay, here's the second question. What do you think most people will say is the capital of Brazil? Maybe you thought the capital was Rio de Janeiro, but maybe you knew the right answer, Brazilian. By looking at the results of those two quick polls, I can tell you with no prior information that the capital of Brazil is Brazilian.
正确答案是47天，因为睡莲的面积每天都在翻倍。如果它们在第48天填满湖泊，它们在第47天就会填满半个湖泊。但直观的答案是第24天，因为24是48的一半。如果你问人们答案是什么，
How would I know that? Because if I think Rio de Janeiro is the capital of Brazil, I will also think that most people think that. However, if I think Brazil is the capital of Brazil, I will still think the Rio is the answer that most people will give. So what this ends up being is that Brazilia will be an answer that's more popular than people expect. I have to say it took me a minute to understand how this idea works. It's complicated, but it really
大多数人会说24，少数人会说47.当你问人们他们认为别人会说什么时，几乎每个人都会预测别人会说24。既然更多的人说答案是47，那么超出预期的是其他人也会说答案是47. 47结果证明是“惊人受欢迎的投票”答案，也是正确的答案。这基本上是一种弄清楚谁拥有专家或内部信息的巧妙方法。预测市场也是基于类似的理念。如果群体中有人对某事有所了解，你给他们经济激励让他们公开
is very clever. Here's another example. Let's look at a math problem. In a lake, there's a patch of lily pads. Each day, the patch doubles in size. If it takes 48 days for the patch to cover the entire lake, how long would it take for the patch to cover half the lake? The correct answer is 47 days, because the lilies double in area every day. If they fill the lake on day 48, they will fill half the lake on day 47. But the intuitive answer is the 24th day, because 24 is half a 48. If you ask people what the answer is,
这些信息，你就能把内部信息浮出水面。“惊人受欢迎的投票”往往能在许多不同领域预测出正确答案。它可以是事实性的，可以是数学的，甚至可以是估计艺术品的价格。所以他们做了一个小研究，让麻省理工学院的学生估计艺术品的价格。现在，麻省理工学院的学生在大多数情况下，对艺术并没有太多的了解。然而，当要求他们估计艺术品的价格并说出其他人会对此有什么看法时，他们
most people will say 24, a few people will say 47. When you ask people what they think others will say, nearly everyone will predict that others will say 24. Since more people say the answer is 47, then expect others to say the answer is 47. 47 turns out to be the surprisingly popular vote answer and the correct one. It's basically a clever way to figure out who has expert or insider information. Betting markets work on a similar idea. If there's someone in a group who has knowledge about something and you give them a financial incentive to come forward
采用了“惊人受欢迎的投票”，“惊人受欢迎的投票”完全说中了。我与塔利的对话以探讨最后一个关于我们如何才能说服他人倾听真相的想法而告终。这与一项针对普林斯顿大学学生的研究有关，他们在聆听一个名叫安娜贝尔的年轻女性的故事时扫描了大脑。制作人雷内·克拉尔宣读了该故事的一个片段。我知道每个人都有一些疯狂的舞会故事，但是，嗯，等着瞧吧。我是迈阿密的一名高一新生，我是新生界的新人。
with that information, you can bring insider information to the surface. So the surprising popular vote tends to predict the correct answer in many different domains. It can be factual, it can be math, it can be even estimating the price of art. So they did a little study where they asked MIT students to estimate the price of art. Now, MIT students, for the most case, they don't really have a lot of knowledge about art. And yet, when they asked them to estimate the price of art and also to say what other people will think about that, and they
我是高中界的新人，我应该这么说。当时快到十二月了，所以我上高中大约三个月了，这个叫查尔斯的男孩约我出去。他是英国人，是个高三学生，所以我上高中大约三个月了，这个叫查尔斯男孩约我出去。他是英国人，是个高三学生，而且真的很帅。但有点害羞，不过，嗯，没关系。所以我答应了，我很兴奋。故事还在继续。正如塔利所写，其中包含爱情、拒绝、血、酒精以及几名警察，具备了一本畅销书的所有要素。
took the surprising popular vote, the surprising popular vote, the spot on. I wrapped up my conversation with Tali by exploring one last idea about how we might convince others to listen to the truth. It had to do with a study of Princeton students who got their brain scanned while they listened to a story of a young woman named Annabel. Producer René Clarre read an excerpt from that story. I know everyone has some crazy prom stories, but well, just wait. I was a freshman in high school in Miami, Florida, and I'm new to the freshman scene.
我请塔利告诉我，当普林斯顿大学的学生听这个故事时，他们的脑海里发生了什么。这是普林斯顿大学哈桑教授团队进行的一项研究。他们表明，当一个人听另一个人的故事时，两个人大脑中的活动会同步。所以如果你在听我说话，那么你大脑的活动看起来很可能和我大脑的活动非常相似。一开始，你大脑中倾听我大脑的活动会稍微延迟一点，对吧？所以我正在想一些事情，我在说这些词，你在感知这些词，然后你大脑中的活动会跟随我大脑中的活动。
I'm new to the high school scene, I should say. And it's almost December, so I've been in high school for about three months, and this boy Charles asks me out. He's British, he's a junior, so I've been in high school for about three months, and this boy Charles asks me out. He's British, he's a junior, and he's really cute. But sort of shy, but just, well, it doesn't matter. So I say yes, I'm excited. The story goes on. It includes, as Tally writes, love, rejection, blood, alcohol, and a couple of policemen, all the requirements of a bestseller.
然而他们在研究中发现，过了一会儿，听众的大脑开始领先于讲故事的人的大脑。因为听众的大脑在预测讲故事的人会说什么。如果你看一下听众的大脑，你就可以预测安娜贝尔大脑中的活动会是什么样子。但这种同步的概念对于影响力似乎很重要。为什么？同一团队的另一项研究发现，当人们在听非常有力的演讲时，他们发现听这些演讲的不同人群的大脑开始同步。
I asked Tally to tell me what happened in the minds of the Princeton students as they listened to that story. So this is a study that was conducted by Professor Hassan's group at Princeton. And what they showed is that when one person listens to another person's story, the activity in the two brains synchronize. So if you're listening to me, then it is possible that the activity of your brain looks a lot like the activity in my brain. And at the beginning, the activity in your brain, listening to my brain, it will be delayed in a little bit, right? So I'm thinking about something, I'm saying the words, you're perceiving the words, and then the activity in your brain will follow the activity in
所以如果我们都去听，例如，肯尼迪著名的登月演讲，我们的大脑看起来可能会非常相似。我们前面的人确保了这个国家引领了工业革命的第一波浪潮、现代发明的第一波浪潮以及核能的第一波浪潮。而这一代人不打算在即将到来的太空时代的尾流中失败。我们打算成为其中的一部分。我们打算引领它。”这不仅发生在对语言和听觉很重要的区域。它也发生在对情感很重要的区域，在对
mind. However, they found in that study that after a while, the brain of the listener started proceeding the brain of the storyteller. Because the brain of the listener was predicting what the storyteller will say. So if you looked at the listener brain, you could predict what the activity in Annabelle's brain would look like. But the idea of synchronization seemed to be important for influence. Why? In another study that the same group did, they found that when people were listening to very strong speeches, what they found was the brains of the different people listening to those speeches started synchronizing.
所谓的心理理论（我们思考其他人正在想什么的能力）很重要的区域，在对联想很重要的区域。你试着去想，所有这些具有影响力的演讲有什么共同点，能让这么多人的活动同步？其中最重要的事情之一就是情感。如果讲故事的人或发表演讲的人能够引发另一个人的情感，那么他实际上在某种程度上对那个人的精神状态有了一定的控制。所以，可以这样想。
So if we all listen, for example, to Kennedy's famous moon speech, her brains would likely look very much alike. Those who came before us made certain that this country rolled the first waves of the industrial revolution, the first waves of modern invention, and the first wave of nuclear power. And this generation does not intend to founder in the backwash of the coming age of space. We mean to be a part of it. We mean to lead it." And this is not only in regions that are important for language and hearing. It's also in regions that are important for emotion, in regions that are important for
如果你非常伤心，而我在给你讲笑话，好吧，你很伤心，所以你不会像我快乐时那样以我感知笑话的方式去感知它。但如果我能先让你快乐，然后再给你讲笑话，好吧，那么你就会更多地从我的角度去感知它。因此，通过引发情感，你能够做的是改变对随之而来的一切事物的感知。像发表演讲的人希望你感知的那样去感知信息。所以你可以看到这种耦合，即受众的大脑和演讲者的
what's known as fear of mind, our ability to think about what other people are thinking, in regions that are important for associations. And you try to think, well, what's common to all these influential speeches that can cause so many people's activity to synchronize? And one of the most important things is emotion. If the storyteller or the person giving the speech is able to elicit emotion in the other person, then he's actually having somewhat of a control on that person's state of mind. So, think about it like this.
大脑在某些方面耦合在一起的想法。你可以看到这如何有可能被用来传播好的信息。你在高中有个好老师，你被老师迷住了，被老师讲的故事（也许是关于历史或地理的）深深吸引。但你同样可以看到，同样的事情如何在相反的方向起作用。你可能在听一个煽动者的演讲，或者你可能在听一个具有某种非常迷人的修辞风格的人的演讲。这个人也可以把你引向歧途，就像
If you're very sad and I'm telling you a joke, well, you're sad, so you're not going to perceive the joke as I perceive it when I'm happy. But if I'm able to first make you happy and then tell you the joke, well, then you perceive it more from my point of view. So by eliciting emotion, what you're able to do is change the perception of everything that comes after. To perceive information as the person who's giving the speech wants you to perceive it. So you can see how this coupling, this idea that the audience is mind and the speaker's
无论一个人是出于好意还是恶意，我们是否会被一个人影响或忽视另一个人，其影响因素都是一样的。影响你是否具有影响力的因素可以是：你能否激起另一个人的情感？你能否讲一个故事？你是否考虑了你面前这个人的精神状态？你是否给了他们符合他们先入为主观念的数据？所有这些让一场演讲比另一场演讲更有影响力或更有可能产生影响的因素，
mind are in some ways coupled together. You can see how this could potentially be used to spread good information. You have a great teacher in high school and you're captivated by the teacher and you're being pulled along by the story the teacher is telling you, maybe about history or maybe about geography. But you can also see equally how the same thing can work in the opposite direction. That you could be listening to a demagogue or you could be listening to somebody who has a very sort of captivating rhetorical style. And this person could also lead you astray in just the same way that the whether we will be influenced by one person
既可以用于善，也可以用于恶。塔利·沙罗特，我要感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。本周的节目由玛吉·彭曼和雷娜·科恩制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。特别鸣谢我们的前实习生克洛伊·康纳利，她采访了我们在本节目开始时听到的自由派和保守派人士。我们的工作人员包括珍妮·施密特、帕特·沙阿和雷内·克拉尔。我们本周的无名英雄是国家公共媒体的布赖恩·马尔福德。
or ignore another person are the same whether the person has good intentions or bad intentions. The factors that affect whether your influential can be, can you enlist it in motion in the other person? Can you tell a story? Are you taking into account the state of mind of the person that's in front of you? Are you giving them data that confirms to their preconceived notions? All those factors that make one speech more influential than the other or more likely to create an impact
NPM是负责销售我们赞助信息的团队。布赖恩是自由派和保守派的绝佳混合体。他在鼓励方面总是表现得自由派，而在承诺方面则表现得保守派。俗话说，他承诺得少，交付得多。谢谢你，布赖恩。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是NPR。这个节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
can be used for good and can be used for bad. Tali Sharad, I wanna thank you for joining me on Hidden Brain today. Thank you so much for having me. This week's episode was produced by Maggie Penman and Raina Cohen and edited by Tara Boyle. A special shout-out to our former intern Chloe Connelly, who interviewed the Liberals and Conservatives we heard at the start of this episode. Our staff includes Jenny Schmidt, Parts Shah and Renee Clar. This week our unsung hero is Brian Malford of National Public Media.
可以用于行善，也可以用于作恶。塔利·沙拉德，非常感谢你今天来到“隐藏的大脑”。非常感谢邀请我。本周的节目由玛吉·彭曼和莱娜·科恩制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。特别感谢我们的前实习生克洛伊·康纳利，她采访了我们在节目开始时听到的自由派和保守派。我们的工作人员包括珍妮·施密特、帕特·沙阿和蕾妮·克拉尔。本周我们的无名英雄是国家公共传媒公司的布赖恩·马尔福德。
NPM is the group that sells our sponsorship messages. Brian is a great mix of liberal and conservative. He's always liberal in his encouragement and conservative in his promises. As the saying goes, he under promises and over-delivers. Thanks Brian. I'm Shankar Vidantum and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
NPM是负责销售我们赞助信息的团队。布赖恩完美地融合了自由派和保守派的特点。他在鼓励他人时总是像自由派一样慷慨，而在许下诺言时则像保守派一样谨慎。俗话说得好，他承诺得少，但做得多。谢谢你，布赖恩。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。